buonasera
bentrovati prima di cominciare io questa
busta la vorrei mettere qua
e così sapete che c'è una busta che ci
servirà più tardi
dopodiché io vorrei fare in realtà un
passo indietro anzi in effetti 25 passi
indietro perché dovete sapere che quando
io ero bambino ero appassionato di
giochi di ruolo
passavo i miei pomeriggi a scrivere
avventure che poi i miei compagni di
gioco avrebbero vissuto ed interpretato
insieme a me attraverso un foglio a una
penna una manciata di dadi e soprattutto
tanta tanta immaginazione
adoravo creare questi mondi e questi
scenari immaginari nei quali immergere i
miei amici perché adoravo scoprire come
ognuno di loro si sarebbe comportato
quali scelte
avrebbe compiuto all'interno dei mondi
che io avevo creato per loro certo
questi mondi questi scenari dovevano
essere sufficientemente elastici per
dare a loro la sensazione di libertà di
scelta e libertà di movimento ma
contemporaneamente non troppo affinché
io potessi rimanere in qualche modo in
controllo della vicenda della situazione
si potrebbe dire quindi che già
all'epoca dovevo trovare il giusto
equilibrio tra libertà di scelta e
controllo da parte mia
ecco 25 anni dopo
se mi guardo indietro e ripenso a quei
giorni beh non mi sembra un caso che io
oggi sia un mentalista perché in effetti
il mentalismo è fondamentalmente simile
noi potremmo definire il mentalismo in
questo modo costruire realtà inventate
che producono risultati concreti e se ci
sono degli psicologi qui in sala
riconosceranno
questa definizione ma per quanto mi
riguarda la definizione perfettamente
calzante anche del mentalismo certo le
differenze rispetto ai giochi di ruolo
erano che sono che se nei giochi di
ruolo i mondi che io creavo da bambino
erano fatti di draghi mostri da
sconfiggere tesori da scoprire e
quant'altro il mentalismo è
fondamentalmente una sorta di meta
teatro sulla comunicazione cioè in altre
parole un modo spettacolare in modo
suggestivo teatrale metaforico di
giocare anche in effetti esplorare i
meccanismi della comunicazione e anche
le trappole e le illusioni della mente
ma per non rimanere troppo sull'astratto
io vorrei darvene subito una
dimostrazione molto rapidamente e quindi
per farlo vorrei partire da una una
storia una storia di stampo vagamente
zen e quindi possiamo immaginarci tutti
quanti su una collina in cima ad una
collina in compagnia di un maestro di
tiro con l'arco che ha circondato dai
suoi studenti dai suoi discepoli
siamo arrivati su quella collina nel
momento preciso in cui il maestro di
tiro con l'arco e pronto a scoccare la
freccia punta in direzione della vallata
ai piedi della collina dove c'è una
foresta
ora tutti gli studenti tutti i discepoli
sanno che lì dentro a quella foresta tra
gli alberi c'è nascosto un bersaglio ma
da dove si trovano a loro neanche
riescono a vedere questo bersaglio
ciononostante il maestro sembra molto
sicuro di sé addirittura un secondo
prima di scoccare la freccia chiude gli
occhi un ultimo respiro
la freccia viene scoccata tutti gli
studenti guardano la festa sibilare
nell'aria infilarsi dentro i rami della
foresta
a quel punto il maestro fa un cenno e
tutti i discepoli cominciano a correre
su per la collina alla ricerca della
freccia appena scoppiata
per trovarla là in mezzo agli alberi
perfettamente piantata al centro del
bersaglio
ecco dovevo fare questa piccola
introduzione perché adesso tutti voi per
i prossimi cinque minuti
diventerete in un certo senso il mio
arco e le mie frecce torna in gioco
quella busta che io ho messo lì prima di
cominciare e ho anche bisogno di
qualcuno
scendo giù non abbiate paura non è che
mi metto a leggervi il pensiero adesso
per carità
vediamo un po ciao ti fa divenire una un
secondo sul palco raggiungimi più veloce
che puoi perché come sai qui abbiamo i
minuti davvero contati come ti chiami
lorenzo questa come la copertina di
linus che è rimasta attaccata alla mano
lascia al fazio ci si lasciano il
secondo li hai detto il tuo nome
perdonami li lorenzo lorenzo facciamo
così io qui ho un dado sapete che
all'inizio parlavo dei giochi di ruolo
una manciata di dadi allora mi sembrava
il caso di poter utilizzare più che
altro perché così tutti sanno che le tue
scelte saranno casuali dettate dal dado
lorenzo quello che tu dovrai fare è
questo diciamo dare una sorta di
mescolata al dado poi ti fermi così
lasciando che il dato si riposi sul
palmo della tua mano
prova tu stesso prova a mescolare una
volta il dado molto rapidamente e poi ti
fermi così con la mano ancora coperta
ecco agita e poi ti fermi così perfetto
in questo caso si alzi la mano è uscito
il numero ve lo faccio vedere a voi che
siete in prima fila
questo è il discorso questo è quello che
dovrei fare tu d'accordo lorenzo questo
è il chilo che conta diciamo questa fino
ad essere solo per spiegarti agita ferma
ma non ho stare ancora la mano rimane
fermo così quando ti sembra di aver
mescolato il dado a sufficienza ok va
bene per fatto rimane così fermo così
ho bisogno di voi
un dado come sapete a sei facce
vediamo tu hai già guardato qual è il
risultato che c'è nel dato no sicuro
vuoi controllare notini ancora artini
ancora così tiene ancora stretto così mi
vorrebbe dire per favore non so they
mescola ancora dai mescola ancora e poi
ti fermi si è mescolato il dato perché
abbiamo visto che vi mescolato tra due
volte era venuto tutto sempre uno vero
guardarci thun secondo di miss è uscito
ancora uno fermati lì guardaci
chiaramente se mesco ritenendo il dado
pigiato stretto tra le mani non si
mescola è cambiato si rimane fermo così
mi raccomando ok allora dicevo di temi
ad alta voce per piacere facciamo dei
paesi nel senso delle nazioni o dei
continenti ad alta voce asia l'italia
intanto comincia a scrivere asia italia
a me ho sentito
vabbè si iscrive a passava così a z che
sta per azerbaigiano e bere
ho sentito america chi l'aveva detto al
si amano si facciamo usa per capirci
meglio ancora due rapidi cina e messico
cina e maxi ma facciamo un ex che sta
per messico
lorenzo quale numero uscito tu lo sai
già perché aveva controllato che non
fosse lo stesso di prima
4 ve lo faccio vedere qui in prima fila
potete vedere e quindi ecco asia italia
s'è persa 4 è usa cioè america
ricordiamoci di questa cosa
lorenzo mescola ancora quel dato poi ti
fermi lynch ditemi visto che è venuto
fuori uf6 miri volgo alle donne
soprattutto di temi i nomi di a famosi
attori americani ad alta voce si ancora
clooney brad pitt marlon brando allora
scusate george clooney brad pitt e
marlon brando e detto vero comincio con
questi se no allora clooney cui un kit
brando altri tre dai
come di caprio di caprio
al pacino
pacino ancora un ultimo andate poco al
cinema ragazzi miei siete troppo
impegnati tom cruise grazie lorenzo qual
è il numero che è uscito uno lo faccio
vedere quindi abbiamo più cool e clooney
sarebbe george clooney lorenzo ultima
volta mescola ancora il dado quindi
abbiamo america george clooney ci sei
fermo lì
ditemi questa volta facilissimo l'ultima
cosa che vi chiedo di temi dei colori
arancio verde giallo o sentito alzate la
mano che ha detto arancio e verde giallo
siete timidi va bene ok allora verde
arancio giallo azzurro
come viola e rosso vi ho sentito verde
arancio giallo azzurro viola e rosso
lorenzo che numero è uscito questa volta
due o ogni volta un numero diverso mi
pare perché la prima volta george esatto
george clooney era il 4 cioè scusami
america era il 4 george clooney era
l'uno stavolta è uscito il 2 che arancio
arancione in poche parole perfetto e lo
mettiamo qua benissimo lorenzo recupero
il dato che non ti serve più ma tu
prendi per cortesia la busta aprila tu
stesso e cerchiamo di mostrare quello
che c'è dentro in camera da quella parte
perfetto questa busta non ti serve anzi
sai cosa ti dico io il dato intanto te
lo regalo cioè giocato tu mettiti oppure
in tasca
ora vediamo se riusciamo posso prendo un
secondo e io perché così vediamo di fare
vedere
vi ricordate le scelte che sono state
fatte liste di cose nominate da voi
stessi incrociate con la casualità del
tiro del dado 26 cioè america
george clooney arancione arancio arancio
george clooney america america
ciascun e arancio immaginato che io sia
una sorta di maestro di tiro con l'arco
e che questo fosse il mio bersaglio
è la locandina di un film the american
con george clooney chiaramente bella
arancione lorenzo grazie per avermi
aiutato questo lo puoi tenere grazie
mille fate un applauso anche al mio
improvvisato aiutante era per darvi una
dimostrazione pratica insomma ora
resistete alla tentazione di non
seguirmi più e di cominciare a pensare
come io sia riuscito a fare questa cosa
vi prometto che mi se continuate a
seguire per un attimo in un certo modo
in un certo senso ci arriveremo perché
io francamente per essere onesto sulla
mia disonestà
vorrei ritornare un secondo alla storia
del maestro che vi ho raccontato prima
possiamo davvero immaginare a tutti
assieme come se fosse la scena di un
film visto che abbiamo appena giocato
con la locandina di un film
e allora torniamo lì nel momento preciso
in cui maestro sta per scoccare la
freccia si concentra fu la freccia parte
si infila e sparisce dentro la foresta
stacco cambio di location siamo già
dentro la foresta e c'è un nuovo
personaggio in questo film un
personaggio di cui noi non conoscevamo
l'esistenza e forse il discepolo più
vicino al maestro anche lui osservava
tutta la scena in religioso silenzio
osserva la freccia infilarsi sparire
dentro la foresta raggiunge questa
fredda ma portandosi un bersaglio in
spalla trova la freccia appoggia il
bersaglio lì di fianco stacca la fresa
dal suolo
la pianta al centro del bersaglio per
poi dileguarsi
un secondo prima che arrivi tutto il
gruppo dei discepoli che naturalmente
rimane assolutamente basito dalla
precisione incredibile del maestro ne
avete seguito un trucco direte voi
un banale truccolo so messa giù così mi
rendo conto che sembra
può sembrare una grande delusione ma per
me non lo è
nel senso che in effetti questa idea
questa immagine che vi ho appena
descritto e raccontato è ciò che mi ha
permesso di pensare scrivere e poi
realizzare qui live
quello che è successo poco fa certo io
non avevo bisogno di discepoli o
complici nascosti qui tra le scenografie
del ted però si potrebbe dire che quello
che io ho fatto è stato proprio spostare
il bersaglio e l'ho fatto soprattutto
con le parole attraverso le parole io ho
calato le vostre scelte e le mie azioni
all'interno di una narrativa che desse a
voi l'illusione di libertà o casualità
di scelte e contemporaneamente lasciasse
a me il completo controllo sul risultato
voi vi chiederete questo come possiamo
applicarlo a che cosa si può servire
come può essere importante tutto questo
al di fuori del mio specifico lavoro dei
miei spettacoli del mio mentalismo è la
parola chiave qui e narrativa
poco fa ho detto che ho calato le mie
parole all'interno di una narrativa
calato le vostre scelte e le mie azioni
no la parola chiave è narrativa perché
costruire narrative non è una
prerogativa dei mentalisti non è una
prerogativa nemmeno degli scrittori o
dei poeti o degli artisti e nemmeno dei
bambini appassionati di giochi di ruolo
questo è il punto ognuno di noi
costruisce consciamente o inconsciamente
le proprie narrative in continuazione e
lo facciamo perché siamo programmati per
dare significato alle cose siamo
programmati per dare significato alle
cose è la più grande illusione che la
nostra mente opera su noi stessi è
quello di confondere e scambiare il
significato che noi diamo per la realtà
oggettiva ma noi abbiamo sempre comunque
bisogno di dare significato
alle cose e lo facciamo costantemente
inevitabilmente ad esempio spesso
collegando eventi tra loro attraverso un
classico meccanismo di causa effetto
magari a volte in maniera assolutamente
arbitraria e soggettiva senza rendersene
conto minimamente ad esempio parlando di
causa effetto no chiaramente io so che
se premo il bottone di questo
telecomando
la cambierà l'immagine su quello schermo
causa effetto
allo stesso modo voi sapete che è stato
scelto il colore arancione e prima
george clooney per esempio perché voi mi
avete detto fra i vari colori qualcuno
ha detto arancio qualcuno ha detto verde
qualcuno ha detto giallo e poi il lancio
del dado ha decretato in questo caso il
2 in questo caso l'uno tra i vari attori
che voi stessi mi avevate nominato siamo
proprio sicuri non potrebbe essere
addirittura il contrario
non vi posso dire più di questo
in realtà anche io ho i miei segreti ma
il suggerimento che vi voglio dare
e questo potrebbe essere forse
esattamente il contrario
tra causa ed effetto e questo vale non
soltanto per quello che è successo qui
poco fa ma è una questione che può
riguardare vi quotidianamente
è una domanda molto interessante che
forse si dovremmo porre un pochino più
spesso quando interpretiamo la realtà
che cosa è causa e che cosa è
conseguenza perché in effetti l'ordine
in cui noi decidiamo più o meno
inconsciamente di disporre le cose cioè
le informazioni che noi abbiamo l'ordine
che decidiamo da vita e fa nascere nuove
narrative e quindi di conseguenza
significati diversi
il punto è questo non hai tanto
importante che cosa succede
è importante il significato che noi
diamo a quello che succede
attraverso le narrative che costruiamo
dentro la nostra testa nel bene e nel
male perché se è vero che noi non
abbiamo accesso alla realtà oggettiva
cioè noi non vediamo la realtà come essa
è ma noi la vediamo inevitabilmente come
noi siamo una realtà della realtà
direbbe qualcuno una realtà soggettiva
se è vero che se io noi siamo liberi di
costruire le nostre narrative e di
trovare i nostri significati però come
direbbe magari weekend stain i limiti
del mio linguaggio diventano anche i
limiti del mio mondo
ecco allora la domanda diventa come
posso orientarmi come posso trovare la
direzione per costruire le narrative e
dare i significati più efficaci ed
efficienti in un mondo complesso come
quello di oggi un mondo fatto di
relazioni così complesse e così anche
veloci io non ho una risposta pronta e
preconfezionata non è che sono venuto
qui a darvi chissà quali illuminazione
però vi posso dire soltanto una cosa per
concludere a causa del lavoro che faccio
mi viene nominata spesso una parola che
è telepatia
io lo dico sempre non credo nella per
telepatia in quanto potere
sovrannaturale io non ho nessun potere
a me però interessano le parole e allora
telepatia e una parola interessante
perché etimologicamente parlando deriva
dal greco ed è composta tele pathos tele
vuol dire distanza pathos vuol dire
sofferenza dolore ma anche passione
quindi in poche parole telepatia può
significare passione condivisa a
distanza
ecco io credo che nel linguaggio
corrente noi definiremmo la passione
condivisa distanza non con la parola
telepatia ma piuttosto con la parola
empatia
io ho cominciato a questo intervento
parlando di immaginazione e lo concludo
adesso parlando di empatia e c'è uno
scrittore un poeta inglese che ha
avvicinato molto prima di me queste due
parole immaginazione ed empatia e lo ha
fatto parlando di immaginazione morale e
questo autore questo poeta e percy
shelley che non saggio ha scritto un
uomo per essere davvero buono e grande
deve immaginare intensamente il valore
dell'immaginazione e qui al ted
credo che l'abbiamo incontrato più volte
oggi deve mettersi quest'uomo ognuno di
noi deve mettersi nei panni dell'altro e
di tutti gli altri
le sofferenze e le gioie della sua
specie devono diventare le sue gioie e
le sue sofferenze
il grande strumento del bene morale
conclude percy shelley il grande
strumento del bene morale è
l'immaginazione empatia d'immaginazione
non hanno un peso non possono essere
trovati scientificamente con un
microscopio o con un telescopio
eppure pur essendo invisibili possono
produrre risultati assolutamente
concreti io con questo volevo soltanto
come dire scagliare una freccia
a questo punto sta a voi se vi va
prendere tutto quello che ho detto e
metterlo in relazione in prospettiva con
le dinamiche della vostra vita personale
e anche lavorativa che in altre parole
non sa non vuol dire altro che prendere
la freccia che io ho scagliato armarvi
voi stessi del vostro bersaglio portare
il bersaglio lì dov'è la mia freccia
prendere la freccia e impiantarla al
centro
grazie mille
ciao a tutti